chrisley knows best stars Todd and Julie
Chris Lee the dual behind us a popular
show could be facing a new reality
prison time
that is the Chris Lee's outside court
today where they're charged with
conspiracy bank fraud wire fraud and tax
fraud facing up to thirty years in
prison
each if convicted you know you do the
right thing you know you don't lie you
don't cheat you don't steal this morning
the real estate mogul surrendered
themselves to the FBI a source tells us
they are quote extremely nervous in
court today the Chris loose pled not
guilty were required to surrender their
passports and released on their own
recognizance
on Monday top to Instagram declaring his
innocence quote we have nothing to hide
and nothing to be ashamed of and we've
got a ton of hard evidence and a bunch
of corroborating witnesses that prove it
and today from daughter Savannah do not
be afraid or discouraged the battle is
not yours but gods we grew up in a very
small rural town and now our main home
is 30,000 square feet the Christie's
have always flaunted their wealth on the
show in a year we probably spend 300,000
sometimes more just don't close but now
US attorneys accuse them of hiding much
of that wealth by quote actively evading
paying federal taxes on the money they
earn
they're also accused of cheating a
number of banks by quote fraudulently
obtaining millions of dollars in loans
we're not perfect the Chris Lee's could
now join other reality TV stars who've
been behind bars Joe and Teresa Giudice
and Abby Lee Miller have served time
Mike the situation is still in prison
as for the Chris Lee's alleged tax
evasion from 2013 to 2016
Todd denied it in this 2017 radio
interview I've paid 750 thousand to a
million dollars it's about every year so
the federal government doesn't have a
problem in my tax financially the
fifties are fine and by the way the rest
of chrisley knows best 7th season is
expected to premiere this fall as Planet
[Music]